a rookie chris bubich who's not thrown
above a ball making his major league
debut so this is a little welcome to the
big leagues moment two on and nobody out
and now bubic has to deal with jose
abreu
grounded to franco from a knee out at
second base and the royals get the
double play and maybe now chris bubich
will begin to breathe
exactly what the doctor ordered there
the one two
in there strike three called well he got
himself in a jam and then he got out of
it alice kaikels had to take them out
here for the white sox in the bottom of
the first inning no score now he'll face
salvador perez 2-0 pitch on the ground
to third base monkatta
will feel that one pat the glove a
couple of times throw on to first in
time and a one two three first for
dallas kykel on the white side one on
one out for james mccann
oh my goodness gracious james has his
helmet knocked off and he's going to
first base
wow so here is adam engel now with two
on and one out here in the second inning
no score
2-2 in the air to left to drive for
angle gordon back track and the wall
gone
adam angle bring him home it's three
nothing socks in the second inning angle
came in hitting 455. that's his first
home run first runs driven in but a
wonderful way to start a series white
sox d.h tonight yasmani grandahl and now
the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss and the bat went flying
into the screen right behind the white
sox third base dugout but it's another
strikeout for boobic so he strikes out
the first two batters of this inning and
alberto monteci will be the banner with
runner at first
ground ball up the middle tim ranges
over and got bit by the turf monster
tim gets his feet tangled up again he
slid
they give it a hit so monday safe at
first and salvador perez the batter
royals would really like to cash in
right here and there's a base hit to
left field jimenez has it nikki lopez is
coming to the plate and the throw is cut
off monday is back in second base so a
couple of singles and with two outs
salvador perez gets the royals on the
board it's 3-1
that's drilled right center field and
deep
it will be down and off the wall
and ryan mcbroom is at second base with
nobody out alex gordon will come up
3-2
he struck him out downstairs first
strikeout at a big time for dallas kykel
swing and a missed strike three again
pulling the string
back-to-back strikeouts
left-handed he struck out twice against
mubitch
that's hit hard and nikki lopez makes a
diving play that's the last out of the
inning ryan mcbroom who has the only
extra base hit for the royals tonight
that's hit well into left center field
robert is back it is gone and ryan
mcbroom
hits his first major league home run and
it's 3-2 in the sixth inning
one out faces empty nick madrigal
on the ground up the middle and monday
is there he threw it away nick's safe at
first and he scrambles on his way to
second base he is in there so it's not
the first hit but it's the first base
for nick madrigal first time on
and it comes on a ground ball now he's
in scoring position so now tim anderson
pinch hit for by laurie garcia
lined into left field madrigal's going
to be waved home here comes alex's first
throw to the plate it is on the money
out at home plate and i'm sure nick
madrigal knows about alex gordon's great
arm and accuracy and now he's seen what
it's like first hand
solaire with a single as last time he's
walked and grounded out
that one got him yep
you could say interference so solaire is
on and michael franco
in another enormous spot
and franco strikes out so he's had a
rough night at the place he had uploaded
he had two men on and the fifth two men
on there and over three in those
situations tonight bottom of the ninth
inning the closer for the white sox is
in this game and alex kalamay
three and two one more time pitch number
ten
on the ground right side jose holds the
line and wins the race one goal jose is
right down there this is a good play if
this hits the bag by the way it's
probably going to be two bases jose
stayed with it made the plate here is
monteci representing the last hope here
for the royals
high fastball cut him down and the sox
win the opener in kansas city
adam angle's three-run home run does the
trick in column a and the bullpen hang
on